[Applaudissements]
pierre
j'ai couché avec ta femme je ne sais pas
te le dire
alors j'ai préféré te le dire par mon
petit chat tu sais le monsieur au pull
bleu qui ne me fera jamais douté qu'ils
ne me fera jamais de reproches qui
pourrait sauver l'amour quand j'ai
découvert que ça existe et qui
n'auraient pu perdurer sur votre
attachement
alors quand on se croise montre moi ta b
je te montrerai mais ananas je trouve
que c'est une bonne initiative pour tous
ces beaux souvenirs qui luttent en
chantant et en pataugeant dans la boue
alors votons en esprit citoyen si le
rouge était une couleur faisait vous
plaisir
si j'étais une bouteille
émerveillez-vous si la mer est bleue la
mienne est morte et en attendant la
prochaine volée d'air je recherche une
femme mûre pour passer des nuits
torrides une poupée qui fasse le bruit
d'un vrai bébé une guitare acoustique
pour affaire sérieuse
une un mouton pour tondre la pelouse car
et si j'avais le blé de ce beau poème de
leopardi et je recherche un bon mécano
pour m'aider à ouvrir les yeux plus
grand encore et regarder à travers un
briochin
sinon rien pour faire taire la rumeur
alors allez guingamp et des bisous à
l'esprit des équipes
espérons que tant qu'il ya du souffle
mireille n'est pas une ville suédoise
car depuis quelques mois je vis ma vie
négrette et je préfère qu'on reste amis
car je crains que ça ne fasse qu'empirer
mais il faut s'y mettre à bras le corps
si tu as du mal à bander alors si vous
souhaitez que l'on vous aime participer
donner quelque chose s'il vous plaît
permettez que je vous embarque sur ma
mobylette
car chacun de vous allez maintenant vers
votre destinée pour créer une rotation
importante de porte-jarretelles sous la
blouse pour que les gens aillent faire
que les corps s'emboîtent parfaitement
pour son enterrement de vie de jeune
fille donc oui oui messieurs dames
je connais la vérité sur la zone 51 et
sur france inter je me laisse pousser la
[ __ ]
il a 10 bits ce qui la fait rire mais
aussi ce que nous faisons à la terre
nous le faisons à nous mêmes bandes
d'enclumes n'avouez jamais jamais votre
soutien aux serveurs du piano blémont
brille comme un adepte de l'apnée il ya
des gens qui dirait qu'il ne sais pas
quoi dire au final saucisses et élégance
et c'est vrai après tout chouette ça
grumes et décroissance thierry roland
nous a quittés cette nuit pourtant le
soleil est à tout le monde
alors j'ai perdu le contrôle de mon
esprit et je n'ai pas voté pour les
banques mais si t'es pas amoureux soit
france steven ta mère tu cherches et en
rentrant si tu peux penser à ramener du
pain sont sous dix ans celui ci tu le
sais bien
je ne suis plus qu'une épave charriés
par les éléments contre la mort de la
vie à ceux sur et discrètement à
l'oreille ni chaud ni chaud ni choumicha
une shon nichons niche michaud dimitri
sors de ton lit du cul du cul du cul de
la chips et du mollard perso j'ai décidé
d'attendre
dimitri retourne bosser c'est la tech à
saint roch
dimitri la france a besoin de toi si
sika sicile saucisson dimitri lâche pas
ton cdi 606 qu'à 6 606 saucisson dimitri
elle est où ta carte bancaire dans la
décadence et la bonne humeur
alors n'ayez pas peur du changement car
kinoshita le matin est un coup et nous
convie à sa douce transe
car l'amour est sans limite
[Applaudissements]
et si que la cohérence serait-ce logique
ainsi que mes désirs sont vos peurs
ainsi que vos cris sont nos droits
si que tes conneries sont ma vie mais si
que l'ennui c'est mon choix et si que
lundi je laisse dolly est ce que
résister c'est tout lâcher et si que
trois fois quatre font du bien et si que
et si que les aigus alors on fait
société on se caresse et on épargne de
la duchesse un mois qu'on l'a convient
après tout la transe et pour tous en
guenilles ou en bas nous et on entre
dans nos têtes comme on en sort d'un la
porte de travers et ses jets géants bien
plus que gênant
c'est même très familier on y retrouve
de vieux cousin éloigné
la recette de la terre glaise l'odeur
des frites à la cantine
le sentier des douaniers et le baiser
d'une maîtresse envolée on nage dans le
lac des souvent et la poésie française
on inspire on s'inspire on y croit bon
si noah on expire on tend la main et du
bout des doigts on décroche le propos
est devant nous l'avenir l'avenir des
futurs souvenirs et la poésie prend son
élan la transe ne fait que continuer
si que des fois c'est difficile c'est
que résister c'est tout lâcher
[Musique]
hier ont célébré les 30 ans de
l'abolition de la peine de mort je me
souviens plus de la suite mais je veux
juste dire qu'il me manque terriblement
c'est pour ça qu'on ne sait pas quoi
dire au final il paraît que selon la
rumeur il ya des gens qui dirait qu'il y
en a marre du funk au fût chantant le
jeudi soir et qu'en bretagne on n'a pas
de problème d'alcool
d'ailleurs c'était tellement réaliste
qu'on avait l'impression de vivre une
scène de film
certes c'est une drôle d'idée mais
pourquoi pas au prix du baril de pétrole
membre à spa marcel m'embrasse page et
la varicelle
parce que nous détruisons la vie pour
l'illusion d'un quelconque profit et le
cadavre exquis de ma vie par en oblique
dans une tristesse temporel
car l'horloge de l'église est toujours
cassé alors tony parker continue de nous
faire rêver des petites miche de pain me
régale du soir au matin et un tuteur de
la liberté toi tony je veux rester chez
maman plutôt que de porter la gueule de
franck toute ma vie alors mort aux
vaches mort aux lois vive les clodos
ivre dans l'oubli qui se moque du maire
coordinateur et des habitants
décisionnaires un nouveau vol de vélos
ces produits et la france a perdu son
triple à on peut souvent jugée l'esprit
d'une femme sur ce qui la fait rire mais
je porte un vieux slip à mon père alors
à quand un vrai conseil citoyen tout à
l'heure j'ai à tanger entendu un petit
garçon expliqué le bonheur c'est simple
comme deux roues il faut légaliser la
ganja contre la hausse de la tva en
librairie et bienvenue à tous les
nouveaux nés
soyez détendu est vrai à prison et en
attendant d'être millionnaire quelqu'un
du travail pour moi
merci
[Applaudissements]